I'm in the small village of yelling in
Denmark and behind me in that central
churchyard are the yelling stones their
wound stones historical markers placed
there by some of the first kings of
Denmark more than a thousand years ago
once they were painted bright colors but
a millennium of erosion has taken its
toll that's also why they're now in a
climate-controlled black box to keep
them safe from the weather and from
vandals the smaller older stone was
placed by King dawn in honor of his wife
Tara but the larger one that was placed
by their son whose name once he
translated to English was Harald
Bluetooth the inscription honors his
parents and then it says Harold who won
for himself all of Denmark and Norway
and made the Danes Christian there's an
inscription of Jesus on the back now
obviously history is messy and
complicated and if you are raising a
memorial roof don't yourself and your
own achievements then you gloss over
some of the less successful bits of your
history but still this is an incredibly
important artifact
it's called Denmark's birth certificate
it's part of this world heritage site
and it tells the tale of a Kingdom
United Denmark and Norway a thousand
years later an engineer at Intel called
jim kardach
was working on short-range radio
technology the sort of thing that might
unite computers and cell phones and make
all those devices speak one compatible
protocol the various names proposed for
the various technologies were things
like bizaar f NC link and low-power RF
which were all a bit unwieldy
Carnac heard the story of how old
bluetooth from a Swedish person that he
was working alongside and they thought
that would make a good codename for the
technology and that's all he was a toad
named the official name that was decided
later was personal area networking or
pan name that stuck until three weeks
before launch when the lawyers said they
couldn't possibly trademark something so
generic with no other options they went
with Bluetooth and that logo Harald
Bluetooth HB
in the rooms of the time more
unless combine those two characters into
what's called a bind room it's also kind
of like a signature and there's the
Bluetooth logo a thousand years ago a
Danish King stood somewhere near here
and ordered those stones to be carved
and raised and now his name is on our
thumbs